these uh curtains that look like the
inside of my brain really bridged
and red
and Blood Sweat and Tears
they're a man of a lot of fluids a lot
of sad fluids sad fluids yeah Blood
Sweat and Tears
I mean that's what makes this alive
right Blood Sweat and Tears
yeah I mean you don't have to have tears
it's gonna say come
shouldn't have been a better better
Joker
yeah what do uh what do your fans like
to hear you talk about
I don't really know they like to hear me
talk about whatever I want to talk about
and then if they're bored by that then
they can tune into something else and
they'll say something else
like uh uh sex
yeah they just want to see what I'm
thinking so they can judge me and
dismiss me
like this person's not good enough
for my time is that your white claw yes
it is
I'm gonna have to wait till someone gets
here and then be like hey bring me up a
white claw
Eli ass where's what's the how does your
thermostat at
um
why does he care I know maybe he's being
a diva oh he yeah he's like I need to
only be in podcast Studios that are
perfect this uh it's a hot it's a hot
Studio it's because you're not like in a
hot Studio it's called this sweat box
sometimes can't really get to the bottom
of things I don't think they're is there
any yeah there's a there's a air
conditioning vent in here yeah it
doesn't work oh it does trading yeah
have you like tried to put a snake in it
uh I'm not like a not like a live snake
but like a tool yeah the tool no I
haven't really done that
Eli Helper and you're live on the
podcast
yep you're late
oh man
I think your van come to the door and
it'll open pull the door handle up unit
two and then come upstairs
so say something cancelable says Joe
Falcone
what's your what's your thermostat at
71 70.
all right cool see ya
he's in for a rough surprise the
thermostat set at that but that doesn't
mean it's exactly it's hot in here yeah
always is
I wonder why you asked me that
yeah I don't know it's probably some
body thing he's really into his body
yeah he is
he uh
um so did you so what happened you did
you didn't snake anything down the vent
no
you think it's just a blockage I don't
know it could be like a dryer vent like
a lint in there a blockage yeah put some
drain around their clothes in it
I don't know you can get to the end of
it maybe yeah maybe we could just clear
it out because that'd be helpful and
make this podcast Studio you could uh
you could get a blower and blow into it
like seal it all off and then blow it
backwards
yeah like that thing well where'd it go
it's not here your event that you made
like the fan vent we could uh
just open the windows
yeah
but it was seeping and it would be loud
yeah come in here
so this is the podcast Eli halpern's
coming
Bridge Hershberger
come on up have you been here before
have you been here before what's up
what's up dude unit two
don't give my specific address but there
are two units let me open a window why
did you ask about the thermostat
I'd just like to know the temperature
before I go in because I had a jacket
that I like wearing
what if I wore it I would have been too
hot so oh okay we thought you were a
diva so we were wrong we're like oh he
probably only does podcasting
temperature of 69. can you hear me
that's what I keep my house at yeah I
cannot hear myself no your mic's not
working oh yeah
[Laughter]
oh yeah I'll just asked the largest man
in Austin comedy
strongest we shouldn't wrestle are you
guys already recording yeah
yeah it's a [__] show
makes sense that's kind of what I
expected
um right now Hans is
opening a window yeah
trying to cool it off it is a little
cold or hot outside
and in here so testicles one two all
right I can hear me now glad you didn't
bring your jacket
yes I made the right decision don't you
think you could have just taken your
jacket off
that's way too smart it's but then I'd
have to remember that it was behind me
oh yeah and then I might leave it behind
you might forget it it's better to
travel light
don't leave anything you guys are
matching
I mean most men wear black I I think
it's just easier I have 10 of these
shirts yeah did you get to the point
where you just like went to a store
you're like all right I'm just wearing
black from now on no I just found this
company that uh hasn't agreed to sponsor
me yet so I'm not gonna shout them out
but they should fit so good they're
really soft and the more I wash them the
better they get that's ridiculous and it
just I never think about what I'm gonna
wear I'm just like oh I'm gonna wear
what I've been wearing for the last two
years I that's that's you get to that
point and then how about your shoes do
you wear the same pair of shoes uh I
have a few different pairs of shoes just
for the comfort level but they're all
black too they're all the same I will I
will give uh some recognition to I have
a pair of Crocs but they're not Crocs
you would never know that they're Crocs
unless I told you because they're
entirely rubber but they have shoelaces
but it feels like you're walking on a
yoga mat and uh those those were great
for traveling the world with you know
what's wrong with sandals is that my
feet sweat in them I'm trying to find
sandals where my feet don't sweat I
don't think you can do that man I think
you just gotta wear socks I have I've
been thinking for years what about Crocs
because I've been thinking about getting
into Crocs I wear socks with the Crocs
really do you sweat your feet sweating
Crocs yeah that's actually how uh my toe
got infected which caused a Cascade of
events that led me to escape the country
so you had a Croc related injury yeah
yeah but not like a crocodile
no just like the sandals might as well
if you saw my foot it looked like the
toe of a dead person I have an idea why
don't they make shoes out of socks
because that would just that would get
gross yeah you need to have a thick
exterior to get all the mud and water
off
believe me I've been thinking for years
on how to replace socks I was just gonna
say I've been thinking for years
it's like that and then just stop there
tap on that Eli Halpern
you've been reacting to punches being
thrown at your face for decades now no
it hasn't been decades it's been it's
been less than three years well 0.5
decades is still a decade no it's not
it's 0.5 of a decade a insinuates one
okay but 0.5 is less than one I'm out
massive Asian right now well you're
interrupting too so that's not really
fair you're allowed to yourself you're
right no you're not you gotta let people
talk so decades you still say decades
after 0.5 so that implies that there's
some decadeness in there
it's like 0.5 decades you've been
dodging fists for decades you've been
dodging it for 0.5 decades
that's like Grant Cardone saying not
interested is a level of Interest it
means they're interested
[Music]
it's like a sales thing listen I don't
know syntax that well so don't look at
me but back to their shoes and Crocs
shoes and socks
so the problem is they Sweat Right
your feet sweat from sandals because
it's leather
uh I don't know I think my feet are just
like trying to protect themselves
yeah I think anything that's just not
absorbent is going to be an issue
um
what about flip-flops flip-flops are
kind of cool because every time your
foot goes up it goes like it makes that
noise and like the air gets a little a
little fan yeah and a little air gets to
go in and then it doesn't it keeps the
sweat away yeah but it's always pressed
against then that's what causes what
this is a dumbest conversation
what about rainbow sandals you ever try
those out I have it what are rainbow
sandals those were like the cool sandals
to have when I was like in seventh grade
in California
they had they're called rainbow sandals
because they're made of like three
layers of foam and then like actual
leather and they were like I think like
sixty dollars and they were like what
the cool Surfer guys would wear in
Southern California and they would mold
to your feet and the more you wear them
the more they mold to your feet and the
more comfortable they get I might uh
recommend those to you thank you rainbow
sandals every Surfers are they still
available maybe yeah yeah they're still
did you have a pair yeah oh you did I
was proud of them so wait leather on the
bottom then I guess leather around the
the plastic no the leather is what your
foot is resting on and the straps that
touch your everything touching your skin
is leather so that's like just absorbent
enough because your skin on skin at that
point you're [__] a sheepskin condom
yeah
yeah that makes sense why they make
things out of leather because it's skin
right do people have leather yeah people
made them leather like Silence of the
Lambs yeah yeah you could make leather
out of anything so is that called
leather whenever it's people's skin
it's your skin in general
it's Heather
human leather human leather interesting
did you guys watch the World Baseball
Classic what if it's female leather is
it feather
feather FH weather white people leather
anyways uh the World Baseball Classic I
haven't but I heard Japan beat America
yeah they did two teammates faced off in
the last of bat it was Mike travelers to
show you atani
I watched the whole game what is my life
become that's fun baseball anything
could be fun that's true
if you haven't watched in a while
I didn't even know it was a thing
till this year
it was pretty cool there was people uh
they were giving citizenships to
baseball players to countries they never
lived in
just to have them play they're like oh I
heard about that yeah Mexico gave a guy
citizenship just have him play on their
team I think and like the Israel team
was mostly American yeah that got my
conspiracy
I didn't know Israel was even in it they
aren't good at baseball but they were
pretty good at news the Jews aren't good
at sports
yeah are they what
what name a prominent Jewish athlete
Sandy Cox Sandy's Koufax yes that's the
only one huh interesting
the
uh that I was watching highlights from
basketball and there was a Jewish man
playing basketball with a yamako when it
was he was like six five it was fun it
was fun to see
imagine if they had a yamaka on the
basketball and that's the only way you
would play
they just super glue it on there
thrown it through the hoop uh it's
ridiculous I would you wear yamaka
no if I had a bald spot that's true you
think that's why they do it
no no
I think it's a God thing
yeah I think so too yeah no the the uh
the thought process behind it is the
yamaka is to separate you from God
but women don't have to wear one because
they're like obviously way less than God
they don't need this separation not my
words that women are actually separated
by God by man so it was God man than
women
no it goes God yamaka am I saying that
right uh man
woman anyways
yeah
no he goes God men dogs women
no wait that's Islam you forgot dogs
cows that's a Hindu yeah
let's just hit them all Let's uh what
about we gotta be fair yeah what's
another uh religion
um
Hinduism Islam Muslim
we I mean we got the big three
Christianity the rest of they're all the
same really yeah Christianity we don't
have Ware hats
that much
we wear regular hats
cowboy hats Cowboy that's the Christian
yamaga
it covers the sides too our guard uh I
don't want to say anything I was gonna
say we need more protection because it's
more powerful
no well you guys aren't worried about
saving as much money
that's why it's so small because it
doesn't take much material
you can actually just use a oven mitt
like an oven you can make 15 of these
out of a cowboy hat
oh it's horrible oh sombreros they got
they got really big rims
half the other Catholics right yeah hey
I think the window opening actually made
it hotter you think so what do you guys
think I think it's just hot in here no
matter what I don't think there's much
you could do I think cons is just like
producing the show right now yeah no
input we're all on I'm not trying to
complain I'm not a diva I can work with
anything
I was just noting an interesting
phenomena in the thermodynamics of this
room Eli you live an interesting life
what have you been up to
um I've been doing a lot of martial arts
training okay I've been doing comedy
every night again yeah because you took
a little bit of a break there oh a long
break yes I was uh
I I don't know
I lost some motivation
and uh I was like well I'm gonna do all
this other stuff and I can always go
back to Comedy because
you know I can't always do martial arts
I can't always fight people I can't
fight people when I'm 60. I can do
stand-up comedy when I'm 60. but correct
and you know I was still doing shows as
when I would get the opportunity but uh
yeah I'm getting back in the grind
because I [__] love it I I was in
Thailand for two months
with your toe yeah yeah so my toe was
infected I couldn't train that's kind of
the foundation for my mental you were
instability Thailand for two months it
was so long that's crazy probably saved
so much money exactly you get it dude so
I went
the way I live my life is I do things as
long as there's like five to ten reasons
for doing it like I don't there's
there's like so many layers behind
everything I do
that so like Thailand was you know I
wanted a mental break I wanted to save
money I wanted a chance to travel again
because I I view traveling alone as one
of the most beneficial things I've ever
done for myself because you know you get
in all these predicaments and deal with
all this [__] but it doesn't feel
like [__] at the time like you get
stranded at a bus stop it's pouring rain
and you're just like well I guess that
happened
yeah yeah that's happened several times
not not this time this time there wasn't
really any serious problems it was a lot
of done it before you're good at it yeah
yeah I'm good at I'm good at rolling
with the punches you're good at
traveling and I attribute that to I yes
I'm good at traveling because I can do
it on a budget a lot of people they say
like they like to travel and they like
stay in a hotel and stuff enough money
yeah exactly
so there's some people that say that
they like traveling as if it's like a
passion of theirs and they'll stay in
like a five-star Resort I'm like bro I'm
like sleeping in a hostel for eight
dollars a night so you're gonna have
problem solving I feel like a lot of
traveling is just being uncomfortable
yeah like in a boat or in a plane which
isn't really that good of a skill to
have but it is useful it's not like oh
good I'm so good at being cramped I'm
one of the best
for people to have something touch their
knees well allow me to immediately
disprove you didn't living in a van help
lower your cost of living because it's
not disproving it
you're adding on to it
in a negative way
um yeah I love living in a van
love being uncomfortable discomfort
getting used to discomfort is good
because then you're resilient and you're
not afraid of discomfort you're not like
anxiously avoiding it you're just like
oh I don't like that so I'm not gonna do
it but I could
so it's not like you're doing it out of
fear how much better did it make it
moving into a place after the van
um it was
uh it was good because like I earned it
and I did like I worked for it so I felt
better it's not like I just lived in a
house my whole life and I was like oh
yeah this is how people live and taking
it for granted and just being like Oh I
need all this and then anxiously holding
on to a job because it could all be
taken away so I'm like I gotta show up
to this job or else I might get fired
but I feel like I uh know that feeling
without even having that feeling I'm
like oh yeah I can see that that's not
that great so I would rather live in an
apartment does that make sense like I I
can just see that that's not good so I
don't want to do it I don't I never need
to live an apartment I don't like need
to like not do it like like you don't
want to do it because like you don't you
don't need to do it that's fine you
don't have to do every uncomfortable
thing in the world but that's just I'm
sure that you do some things that other
people would find uncomfortable oh
that's that's true
so I mean like everyone has their own
battles or whatever that's true yeah I
loved living in a van and loved that it
made me resilient so I didn't have to
have this I I'm choosing to do this
so I'm not like and it gave you a great
uh deal of Freedom too yeah with
traveling so I'm here it's because I was
able to adapt because if my all my stuff
was in New York I'd have to get a
[__] truck and then that'd be a
mental block for me to be like oh I
don't want to move I should just stay
here have you had like uh breakdowns
with the van in like extreme
inconveniences that you had to deal with
I was on the Southern California near
Joshua tree and the car just stopped and
then I had to start it again and then
get to the side of the road and slept on
the side of this two-lane Highway
uh because the car wouldn't move and
then I started the next day got to a
mechanic found out I filled it up with
ethanol and not diesel so it was an
expensive tank of ethanol and then they
had to just drank the whole thing you
can't drink ethanol yeah that's what's
in that's what's in uh liquor it's corn
yeah well not it can come from various
things vodka potatoes but ethanol ethyl
alcohol is what's in liquor it's a very
small percentage because if you drink if
you just drink straight ethanol you die
it'll hurt a lot I've tried it you've
tried it I got it in Mexico and I tried
to I tried to freebase
alcohol
I developed an allergy to alcohol which
is why I don't drink I'll break out in
rashes oh that's good that's kind of
cool
you don't have to drinking ethanol gave
you an allergy you didn't have to go
through the 12-strip program you just
became allergic well for a while I
wasn't an alcoholic I was just suicidal
because I was like I'm just gonna die
and then luckily I got over that I don't
I don't have a problem with alcohol
anymore
suicidal still no you just got over the
suicidal for a few months yeah
but yeah I tried uh I was trying to
figure out all these different routes of
administration that I would could get
drunk because I was thinking the liver
metabolizing the alcohol was the issue
so what if I was able to able to
vaporize it and inhale it and so I tried
freebasing it off of foil and uh should
have seen this coming the whole thing
just lit on fire because that's what
alcohol does yeah and uh you've never
made a whiskey or uh moonshine no moves
that yeah just lights on fire good
disappeared so wait what happened
continue sorry well it just blew up in
my face and I you know Richard priored
myself a little bit didn't try it again
can you tilt it down a little bit more
yes
but so Hans uh my next question was
gonna be do you think that
dealing with those adversities with the
van and stuff has given you some
internal confidence that you can deal
with future issues in that same regard
yeah once you learn how to figure out
problems you can do it in other areas
like learning about learning meta
learning
but yeah that's uh it's pretty fun to do
you have to get better at life you get
faster at problem solving so what what
happened after the mechanic how long
were you stranded for
I slept I slept on the side of the
highway for one day one night and then I
went over to the mechanic the next day
they fixed it the next day yeah really
because I don't [__] up your car yeah
and then I went into the Mercedes-Benz
dealership in Tucson Arizona got it
super fixed
how long did that take uh like two days
oh wow I met my friend Eden there and
did meth with him he was dumpster diving
he's a dude half Vietnamese or a quarter
Vietnamese who's wearing a thong
I was like another guy weird
sounds familiar keep going
what color thong it's like pink
I was envisioning green for some reason
what did you what did you think of math
it was fun it was good but it was sort
of like it felt not that healthy it felt
like sort of like uh like uh like I got
a headache and it's like sort of like
you know it it is what you think could
be like really it's like pounding yeah
it's like giving me energy in a bad sort
of way when did you sleep the next time
like I didn't take a big hit so probably
like 16 hours after
that's what a small hit Jesus 12 hit 12
is that a lot I don't know not sleeping
for 16 hours is a lot it's a lot well
actually if you do it in the morning
yeah
but if you do it in the middle of it
just 24 hours of the day I woke up at
nine today
I woke up at 9 30.
oh yeah I'm awake for 15 hours a day
yeah that's pretty normal so when did
you 16 hours it sounds like a long time
but you hit it like eight o'clock at
night and then waited 16 more hours of
sleep yeah I don't I don't really keep
track but it was uh that honestly that
sounds like a normal day yeah it wasn't
too bad did you uh try to complete any
tasks or hyper fixate on anything I did
stand-up comedy I did an open mic
how'd that go it was fine I mean it
wasn't my best set but it was fun it was
sort of like jittery it was jittery
anxious
it's crazy so you're not scared of like
any doing anything no I I don't think
like that drug is gonna like change me I
think I have power over the drug you
don't have a addictive personality
uh I think I do but I mean it's not like
like every drug it's not like a drug is
can like take you down just because it's
a drug I think
actually I do think that but I don't
think that math is that bad these areas
can do it I don't think that's that bad
it's just bad if you do it for a long
time I mean as far as toxicity is
concerned it's one of the hardest drugs
to overdose on that's why they don't
have meth in uh New York because it
would steal the cocaine and crack market
like if you're caught selling meth in
New York they'll kill you so that's why
you don't see old homeless people in New
York because they're all doing heroin
and if you do heroin long enough you'd
eventually die but there's a bunch of
meth and you know here in La which is
why there's a 70 year old homeless
cracking cocaine is grandfathered in
like we already got a drug here get kick
rocks kid we're like [__] up the
homeless with your [__] bathtub
science
we're we're on that old school Colombian
kid we do drugs the old-fashioned way
inefficiently
and badly
like math is probably better than crack
yeah for sure what's the difference well
meth lasts like
a day and then crack lasts like
a minute
so you have to keep doing crack yeah but
Matthew just had it's it's longer it's
like long lasting yeah it's like those
drugs acting
long lasting
long last what if you mix meth and crap
Time released
that's called you get that that's called
the Gary Busey
that's called the old donkey come
I don't get the reference is there a
reference no sipping well let's see
crack and heroin is a speed ball so that
would just be like a
speed bump
yeah
good job well no let's that would slow
you down though a speed bump away it has
to be it has to be like double fast
oh the the old speed boost
speed boost what's the thing called
Mario Speed Racer mushroom
be called mushrooms
there's already something called
mushrooms yeah dude I've been doing
mushrooms
not to be confused with mushrooms
what was that Speed Racer that chased
the uh
I don't know I forget that's a cartoon
with the white helmet yeah Speed Racer
yeah no yep that was it I like Speed
Racer that's good Speed Racer
racing speed
what
what is this what you expected or did
you expect it to be a little colder
um this is this is exactly what I
expected
I Hans text me hey do you want to do a
podcast right now
and that's how I talk to people so I was
very happy together because if you said
anything else in the future I would have
gotten a little bit stressed out like
I'm gonna have to plan this
that's so true oh my gosh she likes you
but if it's like right now it's either
yes bowed to me it's a yes
I don't like it
it they can sense that right it can get
away from me
whatever oh she's about to turn the
whole pot off so do you guys have uh
brothers and sisters and they have kids
you have nieces and nephews or like
so like how soon do you call the baby by
its name and not it I have no I'm not
near children
are you legally up
no I'm allowed near children I just
don't have any actually I'm gonna be
surrounded by children tomorrow I'm
doing an event for my company yeah he's
about to walk on the power button
surrounded by children that's so weird
well I it's weird because I I've never
done I've never been around about you've
ever done children
the last time I was around children I
was children
but we're doing child we're doing this
event for uh golden Cricket where we're
like giving out crickets to all these
kids which is gonna there's gonna I'm
hoping there's life it's like cigarettes
addicted to crickets yeah the first
one's free
now you gotta eat the whole cornfield
but the whole premise is it's like a
space program
but there's gonna be like space people
there but also kids
and the whole thing is like an
astronauts no there's not gonna be
astronauts but people who work Martians
Maybe
but they're gonna be like Engineers
Aaron not aerospace engineers I think
more along that lines I'm not entirely
sure but important space people is the
was what I'm gonna stick with Houston is
like the space capital of the United
States right
yeah I mean that they have a problem
they've had a problem
but yeah that's it's because we're
closer to the Houston's closer to the
Equator or something it's like the
closest point that's like by the water
so you're not gonna like kill anything
wait is that important oh well By the
Waters well you're gonna kill a lot more
by the water but I know being by the
water is important being by the equator
I don't see how that would be beneficial
yeah because the Earth is spinning and
you want to use the spin of the Earth
and such things shot you because you're
okay the Earth doesn't spin as fast at
the axis yeah yeah very true you're just
going out there limp [__] it at the
polls yeah if you're at the North Pole
it's like driving a car with Cheerios
for Wheels
or Flintstone feet
just going into space just me Heidi from
the equator it's like but yeah her whole
pitch was something I hadn't even
thought of it was like when we colonized
Mars the most efficient way to feed the
population is going to be with crickets
and I was like that is such a brilliant
marketing angle that I had not
considered space food
it's all speaks crickets what are the
Crickets gonna eat on Mars uh we would
have to transport up some kind of
probably like corn soy Dairy combo so
then we have to have Farms on Mars no no
we can we could just we could just
dehydrate them and then send up like all
these pellets
and then
get a Peloton we could just keep I think
we could just continuously ship Cricket
food over
why not just ship food food over because
you don't have an atmosphere to grow
corn and stuff ah man or cows come on
you think we can have cows on Mars I'm
gonna be old-fashioned here milking cows
wanna look up cow on Mars cows would
probably be happy on Mars there's less
gravity if they can jump oh yeah they're
probably the perfect animal first
everybody would be happy on Mars yeah
cows do seem like they shouldn't be on
earth they're just too little heavy
there really has some elephants
crickets oh imagine a cricket jumping on
on Mars I think he's just gonna fly away
are we gonna contain them
you have to build a wall you can make an
airplane out of it yes
well overall is over here
crickets
are loud at night
let's see about all the countries near
the equator are so [__] well as we
could have really have an awesome space
program save a lot of gas
it's it's probably because they're on
the equator is why they're [__] right
the equator I went to the equator in
Ecuador
and which funny enough means equator
but um they have like they have like the
line where it's like that is the equator
what's that drawn with like a traffic
lane it's in like cement there's like a
little park around it and then they're
like actually this time of year the
equator's over there
waiter's work
but um change equators change
are you joking do they actually say that
yeah they say that I don't know the
explanation but that was I didn't make
that up
um but no they did this thing where they
like
they like spun an egg and if you were
far enough to one side of the Equator it
would fall that way and if you go the
other way and you spin it it would fall
the other way so that was very
interesting and the toilets flush the
opposite direction yeah they did some
water swirly stuff
the old water swirly that means if
somebody in Australia is getting bullied
he's getting bullied
opposite his cowlick is the other
direction yeah you can always tell where
they're from he's getting reversed
twirlied so he probably wears his hair
the other direction
this [__] is on the table
cats have such aggressive buttholes
what's
well they don't hide it like dogs
they should they should be ashamed
they're more homosexual
is the butthole a gay genital or is that
for everyone now
well genitals are gay man
everything's
you think so
you think pussy's gay that's gay I think
I
sexuality is just weird it's gross I
don't like that that's why we're here
and that's what we want to do I think
that's not that cool
sex but like what are you gonna do about
it
well I think it's one of the joys of
life
yeah me too a positive thing overall
yeah I think sex is good I think a lot
of people try to control it to use that
Sexual Energy for fuel and money
why are you looking at me
are you trying to harness sex energy for
profit with your crickets and children
no I [__] the crickets
are the Crickets just yours your genetic
replica you're just like I've just like
spliced myself into them yeah we're all
eating your [__] and everyone's no I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna pull this thread
this is a legitimate company
oh yeah
the enemy of riffing is business
what about another animal like a spider
I'm gonna open up a spider shop
yeah you're gonna compete with this
crickets but it's your spiders can eat
his crickets yeah and my spiders are
gonna be poisonous when we're just gonna
sell them to like the FBI to kill people
well that they could shoot web that is
spliced with your [__]
there we go you can impregnate women
from another continent with my spider
come spider comes did you guys put that
on um it was like a softcore porno like
back in the day when we were kids
spider babe and she would masturbate her
it was like she'd masturbated for the
first time after getting bit by a spider
and then came the spider went how old
are you I'm 30.
I never saw that what was it on
Nickelodeon it was it was on like HBO
Max or damn wait it was actually
HBO Max or skin or Max skin yeah Cinemax
could you see like the vagina no
softcore didn't show but it showed the
spider web come
yeah it showed the web shootout
I would you would think men would have
more of that than women because they
don't really shoot out
yeah but no one wants to watch a video
of a guy jerking off yeah definitely not
me
definitely not yeah that's weird so
Taboo it's almost hot
viscosities in their vagina like some
women have thick
discharge and some women are more watery
so if you could get a woman with like
the thickest discharge
she could throw her a vagina water
around
vaginas are a lot like pasta you know
there's so many different kinds and like
they're all the same but just because of
their shape they feel so much different
you know you got like what a pasta pasta
like spaghetti and penne yeah gnocchi
yeah
it's black chicks Smokey's not pasta
that's potato
I got that thick vagina juice do you
ever see the meme or the cocaine spider
and then the meth spider
in the THC spider
oh yeah no that's not a meme that's a
real science experience oh really yeah
that was real what it was hilarious it's
like and the Met spider was the
cocaine's part I was like ah Papa shot
in your ass oh the video bro that was
that was a joke no but no no but there
there was uh an experiment where they
gave spiders different drugs and showed
the web they created that was real and
it's very interesting well I might have
to look up that longer video yeah I mean
drugs work on any animal we all pretty
much deal with the same
neurotransmitters do I have to get up
you can just do that
what animal does doesn't like uh don't
dolphins they uh they eat the puffer
fish so then they can get high
yes I can talk I can hear myself are you
recording this or is it live
yes I can't hear myself anymore
okay
I'm what
I'm going into the red yeah
yeah oh
yeah is this live yes it's live
interesting
what do the comments say
pray for the cat it's hans's dinner
that's great I'm so happy that just
happened to be the first one yeah wow
these guys are funnier Eli will never
shut up about crickets
Gary it's his oh is that garyvee Gary
needs to show me his tits have you seen
those no dude he's got this like body
suit with like a nice pair of tits and
he's been squeezing them and he's saying
that they feel real and let me tell you
I've been talking to him a little
different lately
trying it out does he want to see if he
wants to do that
I don't know he he [__] blurred it
when he posted a clip I was like dude
unblur that [__] yeah that's you're not
gonna get in trouble and also I want to
see them but he might though but usually
I call gear I'm like hey what's up
[__] you want to go to Denny's
at 3am and I'm like hey what's up man
you want to go do it later you want to
go to Denny's you want to grab some food
no Denny's just too low class for a
moment of that stature
I I would I've uh I've been to Denny's
in a long time but I have been to
Denny's here in Austin
and somebody got their bikes stolen when
I was at Denny's yep it was just it was
cool to watch I was just watching it
happen and the person that got his bike
store and started running after him
there's there's no better front seat for
Crime than Denny's and a motel
right Denny's right beside a motel on
either one oh or a motel yeah oh you're
saying there's crime in motels yeah I
haven't seen that yet I stay in motels
sometimes too when I travel I stay in
motels because they're the cheapest the
one with the door opening to the outside
yeah yeah it's frightening yeah
I always I don't never mind I'm not
gonna say it
I yeah I have a story I don't want to
tell you
hey guys don't try to rob me if I'm in a
motel
that's all I'm saying There Will Be
Blood
No Country for Old Men
yeah I I have not so what do you have to
do tomorrow then
do you have to give a speech or you're
just like setting up a table
uh I'm gonna be showing up at the the
Houston it's some I forget what it's
called but it has the word Houston in it
so you know space Oh Houston Space
something okay so you gotta go down to
Houston no it's in Austin but it's
called the Houston Space something that
makes no sense I know it confused me too
I was like I gotta go to Houston and
she's like no it's called the Houston
didn't it it's in it's on the east side
and I was like okay
we're back on the same page and um yeah
she's like yeah I'm gonna set up a stand
and just give out samples of crickets to
kids in Texas which
might cause some news articles to be
written that's a great costume idea that
is amazing marketing yeah well it's
great marketing so my whole marketing
plan is like I've tried paid ads and
stuff and it's just a bunch of people
like I'm not gonna eat the [__] bugs
and like like I'm the [__] Bill Gates
but I get it though because I get where
they're coming from but what's up to you
but um I've just been walking up to
people on the street handing out samples
and then telling them about the business
and then I just met this one woman who
was super cool and was like this would
be perfect for this event I'm doing and
that's so cool that's why you gotta just
work it doesn't matter what you do you
just have to do it yeah so you're like
barking for crickets exactly yeah what
if you're barking for Hitler did you
just do it because it's work
I mean if I mean work will set you free
according to him
that was his Moto our bait mock fry was
on the gates of Auschwitz no one ever
gets that yeah yes it is a reference to
the Holocaust thing
you gotta talk into the mic
wait I'm gonna slide out
I'll be right back I gotta pee
this is like the little podcast nugget
in here isn't it what's up bro how you
doing how are you good to see you dude
you too man
Hogs what's your
yeah
what's your Cricket what's your method
for booking this do you just see who did
you just text a bunch of people and
whoever responds
because I want to learn from you because
I admire you
I don't think I don't think you admire
my podcast bus bookings I feel like
you're mocking me
well I thought you were too autistic to
pick up on that
um no I'm just curious however
however it'll work well Mr Michael how
are you today
I'm pretty high me too I'm pretty yeah
you get high I bought you some alcohol
do you do that or is your dude I'm
completely sober 20 days completely so
congrats dude yeah
yeah I recommend that everyone go sober
but I recommend they do a lot of drugs
first yeah to get there that's why I'm
sober off like well I quit drinking but
I'm still doing mushrooms and I just
recently started smoking weed
weed is tight it is pretty good it's way
more manageable now that I don't drink
anymore but yeah it will calm you down
alcohol might get you in a mess but weed
will prevent you from getting into
messes absolutely yeah which is good and
bad because sometimes you need to like
live your life and do things yeah it
kind of can make you a little bit too
much of a [__] to where you don't want
to like take a chance if you're too high
and that can I've been home all week and
I've also been high yeah yeah so yeah
that yeah there's the excess that's the
result of the excess in my opinion look
at that beautiful shot I don't want to
get [__] done but yeah I mean weed is
just such a Interesting Drug
s people a little more like aware and
that's why the government doesn't like
it is because it awakens people a little
bit
yeah it's the glasses from they live
see you see the [__]
see the [__] dude I like them vipers
they're comfortable they look awesome
dude I'm gonna take them off I wonder if
they were created in Pittsburgh
I know I feel like I'm playing poker
it's like the poker podcast [__] well
you have you have friendly eyes
is that an Asian joke I feel like that
was a jab at Asians you you
friendly-eyed Asians it was not racial
at all I just have crazy eyes and I want
to hide them
show us your eyes yeah you do have crazy
eyes
you're making them crazy
yeah but you got the eyes of a man on a
Chevrolet sales floor that's what you
got yeah you look like you're about to
look me in my eyes and be like you're
signing the lease on this 2023 Chevy
Traverse right now you slide the paper
to me and I'm like oh I got friendly
eyes and I sign it
he walks up to me he walks up to me on
the left oh you got you got some
friendly eyes
you guys and I see those eyes looking at
that Chevy Traverse you've got some
gregarious fingers having said that I
also do not feel comfortable saying your
Instagram handle
a c and that's kind of like the
double-edged sword you guys know each
other
yeah I know a little bit I knew Eli a
little bit he sells Cricket chocolate
yeah we're just talking about that he's
going to sell it to a bunch of kids
do eat bugs
that's like your main demographic hey
kids you like bugs you're like yeah
we wrapped them in chocolate
to be clear they're powderized and made
into a protein bar right right candy I
know but you should Market uh bug candy
to Children I'm giving you a million
dollar idea right now you can have it um
it's not a bad idea those kids are gonna
go home and they're just gonna eat
crickets you remember when you'd go to
like yeah why would I pay for Cricket
have you ever been to a like a museum
and you went to the gift shop and
there's like lollipops with ants in them
have you seen that yeah yeah that's it's
like I guess that it already exists in
like 20 years you're gonna have like a
vice article meet the kid who found out
a life hack to never pay for food and
he's just been living off backyard
insects his whole life I ate a
caterpillar and I broke out and hide
really Reggie looking like you're
allergic to a caterpillar
it was one of those fuzzy ones that's a
new roast if I ever Rose battle you I'm
gonna be like
uh if I ever battle you up like if I
grew your hair so curly yeah I wanted to
be a caterpillar I'm turning into it
instead of a spider my I'm just waiting
to become a beautiful flat flower he's
still using L'Oreal kids
what's that the kid shampoo you don't
remember that that [__] was chronic dude
baby shampoo smells so good
yeah it does like why don't we still use
it call it adult shampoo but oh dude you
like the smell of baby Shannon
they come off
they're sniffing babies heads like Biden
just
my boy Biden just wants to take these
deeper hips of baby scalps just [__]
he's blessing them that's his own way he
loves Johnson and Johnson whether it's
the shampoo or the vaccine that was
pretty good
he loves Johnson
because he's gay
he wants to put Johnson in a Johnson
come and uh put your Johnson in my
Johnson
come on little boy give me the Jab
good boy having this Jab
what's in it Cricket juice
not Cricket Jews Cricket Jews Jewish
crickets it's funny because the way we
kill crickets is essentially in a gas
chamber oh no
it's uh carbon dioxide yeah so it's ah
like poison oh okay it's poisonous
that's a good way to kill them yeah now
what would be the worst way
pulling their limbs off yeah yeah that's
what I was gonna say Scotch taping them
to a Pokemon card is just tweezing them
apart
oh
is the Pokemon card extra humiliating
yeah he's getting [__] it's not
Pikachu on a [__] Charizard
or uh diggle it
doesn't that sound racist yeah
what did you say that that Diglett that
Pokemon's one letter away from being
awesome
is that a joke okay hit your nicotine
you want to go ahead
I haven't seen anyone with one of those
in a long time that thing's huge
is you this is intense man yeah keep it
in the cart how much does it hold a
goddamn gallon yeah it holds about a
gallon of Vape juice it's so that's not
too bad yeah it's 35 a tank it's pretty
good dude The Vape juice The Vape is
going over me that was dope
all right dude dude Cricket MMA ripping
it dude you got a lot of people asking
to try your Vape yeah if I was gonna if
kovid was still real that's how I'd be
super spreading just here ripped and
what's wrong I hit an Asian guy's Vape
I don't feel good dude I've been feeling
like [__] bro like I can't even go to
work because this is an Asian there was
there's no coincidence The Vape juice is
just the new strain of cocoa just been
asking it out one by one are we all
hitting it I mean did you notice like
the peak of covid of bars really popped
off elf bars
puff bars oh yeah yeah it's a general
term I've seen the elf bars uh I've seen
a video of guys in the elf bar factory
like mouth ripping them and then putting
the little rubber stopper in them to
make them look new like that's how they
were testing them it was just I mean
like a trailer yeah it was a tray of Elf
bars and dude is like leaned over just
are they made in the North Pole checking
each one
do they have a what is that a dental fan
your story perfectly explained it yeah
it sounds like it kind of yeah yeah
they're all just children who got caught
smoking cigarettes
now you gotta hit all these Vapes what
do you want for Christmas an elf bar
the new elf so what do you guys think of
the split screen is it working or is it
not
it looks like
I like it can I turn it down here it
looks like we're in separate places like
it doesn't look like we're all together
looks like a zoom podcast live from
Antarctica
the Equator the opposite of the Equator
so people on the poles they don't go as
fast as we go then right well speed is
relative they're also not as warm as we
are for for us we're staying still
so if you're in this frame of reference
where like you're going with this the
only thing that matters is acceleration
if you're going faster or slower then
you feel the weight but if you're just
like going the same speed
it's like oh he's staying still and I'm
moving or is he's doing still and he's
theory of relativity Einstein get with
it
I don't know Han just be on his scooter
thinking of [__] like that
passing through people it's like dude
I'm accelerating right now
[Laughter]
as he smashes into a car as he's lane
splitting and cussing people out I've
seen the videos bro you get but I was
thinking about that on the way here like
damn I see why Hans gets so [__]
angry on this side of town dude they
can't drive on this side particularly
that much they're too white they're just
doing the aggression thing as a hobby
they just learned from the Mexicans
they don't actually feel this way it's
just frustrating just [__] nearly
killing people in their Subaru Outbacks
and a dog in the back seat like I don't
need to look in the mirror or turn
signal bro this is my Lane now at least
the Mexican is doing it because he's
frazzled his brain is just trauma-filled
or you got to think maybe he got his
license in Mexico where they just don't
give a [__] maybe maybe what's the
driving school in Mexico they're
probably just scared of crashing and
going back to Mexico hang on are you
Asian guys [__] on Mexican drivers
right now
um I have I have never had a problem
with a Mexican driver no I I have I have
yeah they're aggressive I say but it's
not Mexicans they have shitty say yes
but I didn't like what why do they drive
that way I'm thinking like because I saw
a 2017 Nissan something like it was like
a it was a different name but it was
like a 90s Center that they've just been
making for 20 years so like their safety
standards are way different
so like maybe their schools are
different you know what I'm saying like
the way they're learning Mexico is
different than America
of course well then that would explain
their driving habits like when you put a
I've seen a white an old white Boomer
drive through Japan which that was my
dad he was [__] we were stationed in
Japan and he sucked at driving over
there so I'm like maybe it's where you
learned because my dad looks like an
Asian driver would in Japan in America
it's all cultural you're driving in a
sea of other people so what they they're
doing affects you so it's all like a
different context so no matter where you
are if you're the one that looks
different you're the bad driver you're
the different driver
no so if you're An American in Japan
you're a bad driver Asians are different
drivers maybe you're better that's how
you deflect hey are you guys blaming
Mexican drivers
just like well I mean I'm thinking of
like you're defending the honor of
Mexico yeah you really do Mexican
drivers got to be real careful because
of how many people are in their car
laughs
I don't know why they call them cars
they should be called buses how many
people live in them do you ever see the
pictures of like uh the Mexican the
Mexicans going to work and they have
they take pictures from up top and
there's just a bunch of them in the bed
of the truck well Indians go on the top
of trains yeah I've seen the pictures
and videos of Indians just like [__]
3 000 deep on a 1 000 person train like
are you sure there's no tunnels on this
route can you imagine showing up to a
bridge that's 13 foot seven inches and
they just all get scraped off God damn
it I've seen him in the back of it
I've seen them just sitting in the bed
of a pickup truck going 80 on the
highway I thought Indians just drank a
lot of beer
switching different you're mixing up
dots and feathers
they just ride horses
dude no [__] having horses would be
chill that would be cool with going back
to horses bro I work on a horse farm
yeah and the maintenance is it comes it
would come out of love yeah because yeah
I'll give you a little project to do
well it's more than a project because
you actually care about it like you've
got to fix your car it's like oh this
piece of [__] I have no emotional
connection to but if you got to fix up
your horse you're like oh that's my it's
my boy but what if you're like a horse
girl but you like cars and you're a guy
so you're just a car guy
you're awesome horses
horses for men
I relate more to more snow [__] Beat on
it you're a cricket boy it's hard like a
man drive your car hard
drive it hard I mean I sometimes I drive
hard like if it hit it feels bad it gets
hard it's bad for you like in the
morning
the horse is just kind of like a slow
motorcycle
horses are motorcycles you feed
give it hay and say good boy you gotta
change it got four times you go around a
lot slower but it's a lot better for the
environment which is important Ridge
that's true yeah horses are just
motorcycles that'll kill you if they
[__] you in the ass
yeah I never got [__] in the ass by a
motor a motorcycle yeah no motorcycle
ever [__] me in the ass just cause
it's only seen a video of a guy getting
[__] in the ass by a motorcycle
yeah I'm sure someone has done it with
the handlebars oh no I was thinking like
maybe the [__] motorcycle just ran
them over like they fell off and hit the
ground and then the motorcycle rolled
went into his ass yeah like up his crack
Hans is talking about a dude
that's [__] that's a different
completely different I was thinking of
lively he was thinking of
you could get two people on that too one
just push it back and forth oh yeah like
uh the end scene in a Requiem for a
Dream oh yeah the double-ended us
ass too ass yeah can you imagine being
at a [__] somebody's house party like
that they're like all right bring out
the girls what if you're like clearly
you've never had a Hollywood fun what if
you're like a party still you're like in
the corner like not talking to anyone
like ah this isn't that good I've seen
this before
in the corner judging it like yeah this
is still not in the moment your ex just
broke up with you you're on your phone
like texting there's two girls
six feet away from me you're like shit's
whack well I saw a woman in Thailand
give birth to a mouse
so you mean she had a mouse in her [__]
and she pushed it out correct yeah that
was a show that you saw did the mouse
scuba mask no no he has a show can you
imagine [__] a [__] that just had a
mouse in it like she doesn't tell you is
that considered a [__] or [__]
like why is that is that considered a
mouse trap
the Trap being you put your dick in and
then the mice bites your dick and that's
how you find out it's in there because
it comes out like you're fishing on a
fishing line why is your IUD fuzzy why
is your vagina hairy
hey babe I think you're 12. hey babe I
think your [__] has rabies or something
Wildlife coming out of that sucker
enjoying hair from the inside out the
pubes went inside your vagina
why'd your [__] look like a kangaroo
pouch on the inside
someone bit the inside of your [__] oh
no I must note uh
the logistics of this they put a glass
jar up in there and then the mouse is in
the jar so they can breathe yeah so he's
not clawing around at the the uterusalem
you just started doing kegels why a
glass jar that's like the worst idea
glass can break and cut okay okay it
could be plastic I don't know
it's a container of some sorts why is
your NuvaRing squeaking
it's the new IUD I eat your [__] IUD
and a diva cup in one it says eat your
[__] period blood
it just climbs up in your ovaries and
eats the eggs you're [__] the girl
you're like are you on your period nah
it's just a Mouse a mouse will get it it
comes out with just its cheeks full of
ovaries
you get the mouse pregnant it senses a
baby it starts killing it out of
jealousy nah dude you're [__] just
clapping them shits and you're killing
the mouse you don't even know dude
you're in there you're wrecking it dude
you're actually getting blown by a mouse
that you think is a girl's [__] yeah
you hit like a good angle so you don't
realize you just feel how soft it is on
the back you don't even understand
because they can put like almonds in
their mouth so you're like all right
whatever
holy [__] dude you got topped off by a
mouse bro
oh yeah I think mice can do the same
thing oh this is outrageous dude they
they all be talking bro all rodents tuck
you think it's because they have massive
[__]
I mean just scale if it was the size of
a bear it'd be pretty big so then she
just pushed the jar out of her [__]
with the mouse in it you don't you don't
see the jar that's inside baseball that
I'm letting you guys enrage
she was ejecting ping pong balls out of
her vagina more at six yeah you gotta
say it like you're on [__] news or
some [__] there's there's a mouse in
there with a ping pong paddle
it's like no dude you look in there's a
whole Tournament of mice they're all
like 16 mice in there [__] full-blown
tournament dude do you ever see baby
mouse they're so small you could put
like nine of them in there they don't
have any skin they're pink too so you
wouldn't even notice something like
everything looks so comfortable it's
like almost didn't even walk yet and
they just fall out they're these baby
mice there's only one place to put it in
your vagina Madam please be do a service
for the community don't be a selfish the
worst thing is if she like had maggots
in there there's just slice coming out
oh my God
yeah we've already seen that
yeah what is like the most diseased
vagina you think like that got [__] up
just you know like the athlete's foot of
vaginas just poop maybe poop yeah you
know there's someone out there maybe
girl if you ever [__] in a girl yeah you
shouldn't Agreements are the worst
they're wet they're they got they're the
perfect breeding ground for bacteria
you're always no sunlight reaches it
that's why you gotta sunlight your
vagina more you gotta go out there Sunny
lips Yeah Toast toast the Buns during
covert they're like uh you need a sun
your [__] to get vitamin C right oh
yeah like 10 minutes of [__] is uh
equal to an hour in the sun it hits a
vassal
meanwhile they tune into every house
with a ring camera to get data on how
many people actually did it
show me your ring that is a very
perverted name that he had he doesn't
know I actually part of my routine is
sitting outside naked in my backyard for
like 10 minutes yeah ring cameras step
if you haven't went back you can see me
on the ring camera and you're gonna talk
to kids tomorrow more like I'll be
wearing clothes by then it's uh more
like dingling camera you know what I'm
saying hey more like Ping Pong camera
[__] live footage of Asian people
living their day-to-day lives ping pong
live just [__] dude with a walk in
the kitchen just hours on end going back
and forth with his wife two Asians oh
yeah
I think like 24 7 mice vagina
live squeak
live squeak more like live
Peak at a woman's vagina
remember the mice mouse thing let's go
back to that
so Eli what is your thoughts on uh Trump
going to jail
uh so I don't give a [__] I I decided to
stop caring about the news and
conspiracy theories and I don't even
know what's going to be like I don't
even know what's going on with that okay
a few months ago I would have a whole
Spiel but right now what do you care
about I care about you guys because
that's where I'm at right now met us
well I'm gonna stop caring once I leave
what it what is like what is it that
you're caring about because you don't
care about Trump so what is what what
replaces the trump in most people's
brain for you I care about health and
comedy and business and funny and so
what is it business or comedy that's
like Trump going to jail for you
why would he go to jail
because he broke the law tell us tell us
about it just learn us I'll learn you
something guys
Trump's going to jail because he gave
Stormy Daniels money from his campaign
fund and he labeled it like expenses or
whatever he labeled it wrong so it's
like getting components for tax evasion
like technically you did something wrong
and they can come at you for it so they
will I don't feel like it was him it was
probably his assistant Alan dershowitz
well if you have someone working for you
that does something for you then you can
be held liable for that yeah they can
Rico you
they can send a Mexican here to beat you
up hey
hey hey
it's Rico I'm here to beat you up I
really did something wrong man that was
really hurtful man I'm Rico and I just
want to make you let you know it really
hurt people I don't even know if Rico's
a Mexican name Rico Rico he's Rico come
outside okay doggy do me doggy do me I'm
outside
sorry I on the way here I hit Three
Trees because I'm bad driver
we're like cut off four Asians
maybe Mexican drivers are only bad
drivers to Asian drivers who's gonna
have a feud who's in the who's in NASCAR
like who drives a NASCAR Mexicans you
ever see Mexicans
I never see NASCAR
there is a woman Danica Patrick
a long time ago anyway he's tired but I
haven't ruined that huh
what yeah she did she did retire please
just be more self-doubting
um what do you do what do you guys like
to do when you road rage you road rage
Ridge get you a road rager I like to
speed up and slow down at opportune
times to really [__] with people
yeah I do that I do that too
I do that [__] too I guess I'm a pretty
bad driver so if if something goes wrong
on the road I'm like this is probably my
fault yep that's how I am yeah but if
someone cuts me off what a great riff
you guys are such moral people so
hilarious I mean someone cuts me off
Mike my car is pretty fast so I know
that I can always do this and I will
speed around and then slow down 350Z
brake check Tesla oh my God if you meet
another Tesla
even better even better because my mine
is the cheapest one so if I can do that
to a much more expensive Tesla then it's
like oh it's a benchmark you got more
money right now anyone with any sort of
car can be like yeah I can beat him
because my car's shittier no you cannot
go faster than my car if you're well you
can't go faster than a nice Tesla but
you're still talking about how awesome
it is
okay the the accelerate I can accelerate
fast enough to get in front of the car
yeah the electric cars are torquey they
like the moment you press it it's like
mute it feels so unnatural and weird and
I like them but I don't really like it
like it feels like butt sex with a dude
Toyota is working on it easy Toyota's
working on the simulated stick shift for
electric vehicle and that [__] like
really interesting yeah talk about
[__] a vehicle I didn't feel like I'm
in the real car because acceleration
makes me sick speed it makes me feel
like I'm in a fake world where
everything is awesome and nice was that
Rico no that's me that's to me
it's me Rico I feel that exact same way
in front of the W always so these
electric cars they remind me of those
battery-powered kids toys those Jeeps
this is pretty much yeah I mean they're
made out of I mean they're powered by
the same thing the best version of a
Power Wheels
yeah what if there's some dude in a
remote control like would you like to
have a professional driver take over yes
I'm thinking eventually give me Danica
Patrick and she's just on a joystick
driving a car for you he's like oh I
knew a woman eventually it'll be like we
don't own any cars and they just pull up
to our house and we hop in and then
there's just a train of cars all scene
they could destroy you and recreate you
it's empty or we partner with the UFOs
if they could destroy you completely and
then recreate the exact replica of you
and you could just save like seven hours
of travel they're already working on
that with the 23andMe data that was
taken would you do that if they could
just Jew you like in a carbon dioxide
gas chamber and can they re-upload your
memories again and [__] yeah and then
just recreate you it's like I know it's
not me but it's Gonna Save eight hours I
don't want to sit in a plane I want to
go to China [__] you I'm doing it or
what are you not going to be able to I
mean the way like a teleporter like a
teleporter you just want to teleport and
just get re-uploaded yeah have you seen
the prestige the way I see it if you
have two hydrogen atoms and then you
switch their places
you can't really prove that they're not
the same like they're different because
there's two of them so you know that
they're two different ones but I feel
like you could take that same approach
with like creating an artificial human
to the point where it would be such an
exact replica that like the real you
doesn't even exist what if it just keeps
like the more times you multiply or
reproduce your body the more like
[__] mentally ill and [__] you
become with each [__] go around just
like probably only come back a little
bit less there's like five thousand of
you but you're all Gary Ridgeway I
thought you're gonna say Faust
yeah doesn't that happen when you go in
a coma like you like you no that does
not what if you were like like people
have more mental problems when they go
under Anastasia what if you broke every
bone what if you broke every bone in
your body and then they're like okay we
can just reach that's not great for your
mouth now we're talking or uh Wolverine
origin story like where this is going
unobtainium put it in my [__] no wait
that's Avatar you dumbass
that was Avatar just getting [__]
schools
in Scooby-Doo what's the Wolverine one
Wolverine uh
something like titanium but not
vibrinium no that's wakanda but I think
I think it's vibranium I think
Wolverine's made a vibranium too like
Wolverine's made out of
Mouse I thought he was a meme I saw a
meme that said Wolverine could never be
circumcised and I just started laughing
it just his foreskin would just
infinitely regenerate Bro you've got a
human dick or a little red rocket a dog
dick
Wolverine yeah yeah some [__] hype
she's like [__] I'm [__] Wolverine
and I wish that's a [__] anatomically
dog penis just [__]
he doesn't [__] he just [__] her legs
she rubs his belly to completion
he starts doing the leg thing
Eli what's your thoughts on circumcision
uh I think it's weird and disgusting but
oh yeah I would probably do it to my kid
because
that's weird because well my penis looks
really good and women really like it so
I want my son to have that same luxury
no why don't you let him choose then he
can have a circumcision later you want
to traumatize oh should I let him choose
to be a woman too yes
you might as well cut the whole thing
off dude
[Music]
yeah you mean that's the rules
chop that thing off turn the balls in
the [__] lip so what's going on here
there's no good explanation for
circumcision it's the religion explains
it as like a commune with god
what the [__] does that have to do with
God it's God loves Hillsong yes and he
loves cutting your dick oceans like
that's how you love God like don't you
know how to love God it's there's a
story in the Bible where there's this
whole city tiny hats and circumcision
and they're uh they're like hey if you
guys all the if you guys all get
circumcised we won't kill you so then
the whole city gets circumcised and then
they just kill them anyways
it was in the Bible it was one of the
Abraham's I think Abraham that's the
worst way to kill a cricket is to
circumcised them and then kill them
anyways Leviticus 21 22 says uh that you
should eat the six-legged insects of the
earth you should
haven't got the religious angle for your
company that's obsessing your brain
instead of trump
it's like instead of trump you're just
like hey everyone buy my crickets [__]
yeah hey everyone help me feed myself
I'd rather you feed yours Trump is just
Kardashians if I start getting paid to
have opinions on Trump I will take that
route in a second
women and children would you do that
because you're getting paid
yeah you could just join the military
[Music]
more like the chillitary
you're so chill
um why do we get that we get mad at our
dogs when they come on the couch but we
don't get mad at ourselves when we come
on the couch
I get my calories
I get pretty pissed you're like what the
hell did I just do I bought the couch
new so like every droppage is it's like
[__] it gets a little heavier too why
are you jerking off on your couch no you
don't jerk off you [__] it
no you're busting in the [__]
cushions bro right there in the crack
Jesus military more like military
they're killing a lot of people
all right Reggie open nine months later
you open your front porch there's like a
little [__] ottoman on your front
porch like a stork brings you an ottoman
because you've been [__] your couch
couch gets pregnant I'm like I'm
pro-life I gotta keep it yeah
it started out as a uh it started out as
a folding God damn it what's the word
they should have a furniture store that
sells those called Ottoman Empire
it started off as a foldable futon and
now it's like a full [__] living room
set dude
[__] same piece of furniture and
getting it for breakfast yeah
your whole furniture sets just your
weird [__] human Furniture family I
wish that's how reality worked today
well it's a fractal holographic matrix
that can be manipulated by words
independently wealthy
yeah
then tell us how to be like you and
motivate us Inspire us okay okay rule
number one you just have to believe that
you're right and everyone else is wrong
and then find a bunch of other people
who agree with you that you're right and
then you're pretty much good to go
you guys like shoes
no I have four pairs of shoes why do you
like my questions
deal issues
wait back on the Trump thing we were
talking about shoes before you got here
actually yeah we were damn we're talking
about props should we re-on should we
run it back what run it back what's the
verdict on shoes guys you sweat too much
in sandals yeah we want a solution to
socks socks are stupid they have socks
with treads on the bottom but you look
ridiculous there's a person at the
coffee shop today with those feet Hans
is pro Hospital you gotta sacrifice
style for Comfort sometimes brother
but like
do you think that maybe we should be
more Barefoot and the thing that
everyone does is having their feet and
shoes is like unnatural and weird no
yeah definitely because I just got these
I don't think
about it think about their [__] SBS
yes yeah dude I'm breaking in ESPYs
right now it's [__] flip over here
and you got the independence bro you're
a skater where are you from you said
what where are you from I'm from
Virginia
are you still I used to I can kick
flipping like varial kickflip sorry can
you dick trip dig trip yeah dude I've
tripped and fallen on my dick many a
time on a skateboard dude smack you ever
skateboard smack your [__] they
should wear your ball or your cups you
should wear cups all the time
Hans has a promo code for her [__]
especially if I'm doing things with
rails
imagine yeah elves are designed to
destroy your balls Hans you're sponsored
by a [__] uh what is that a
protective cup company what is that
called sheath underwear sheath underwear
I use diamond cup diamond cup you're
sponsored by Joe Rogan recommends really
well that makes sense because I got
recommended it through my MMA gym which
is 10th Planet which is just a
subsidiary of Joe Rogan yeah
I'm just kidding it's just Joe Rogan's a
big part of my life let's name one thing
we all love about Joe Rogan right now
just kidding
I just have to wear a cup because I'm my
friends bullied me a lot they're always
flicking my you work in high school all
the time the answer to the Joe Rogan
question the balut episode of Fear
Factor is one of my favorite things
about Joe Rogan it's like just what
people eat yeah and they're doing it on
Fear Factor and these white people are
looking at a Filipino food trick you're
gonna have culture white people yeah try
this Filipino delicacy balut and it's a
[__] it's a you know what it is yes
yeah I have something to say about this
in a moment okay so I'm gonna explain to
Ridge Hans you know what balloon is
Right balut is my favorite dish it is
chicken fetus white people should be
eating it's unborn
that's almost a chick so yeah it's like
between a chicken and an egg it's like
an embryo like if you're eating a
chicken fetus yeah here's my opinion on
balut
if you're pro-choice that's vegan
Jesus
if your pro-choice balut is a is a
vegetable I was gonna say if you're a
sjw with purple hair do you look at
Baloo and say that's an egg yeah
show them that yeah I mean like Eli what
do you hate about sjws and don't you
think that your side the right has been
on the wrong side of History so why
just like [__] label him as a righty
what's that called
love Cricket protein
what what does sjw stand for
stupid super Jewish woman
what do you mean what does this stand
for what does it stand for what do you
stand for
the goddamn flag boss gets three white
claws image just starts accusing
everyone of being a girl what are you
doing here in this country
sarcastic
foreign
well they are Justice
um but yeah this girl had sjw tattooed
on the inner thigh and she was like an
sjw and I was like what does that stand
for a shitty joke writer
maybe
I could have jokes are so easy because
they are you can just like pick whatever
word you want yeah pick three words that
are funny
[__] stupid [__] Alpha Sigma smegma
wait are you guys coming up with the
word and then also the acronym yes yes
I'm coming with the word and then
working up I'm not even thinking that
far ahead
I'm just coming up with acronyms what
are you doing just criticizing
everything
there was a I was at the the Banana
Phone mic at Creek the other night and
someone had a CM on their shirt and
someone was like hey your shirt's
missing at you it was hilarious it
wasn't killed they killed yeah that's a
good joke that was there the old [__]
joke you said it that's good uh probably
nick uh Nick Vandervoort Nick
Vandervoort thank you for that awesome
contribution he's so good that Eli
remembered it through it great roasts
are you trying to look at the camera I'm
trying to look at the the comments the
last one says this is horrible
[Laughter]
some guys plugging David Lucas
well you don't have to read the comments
Eli they're already in your head
what does that mean what it means like
you think like a YouTube commenter
that was very meta did I use that right
oh wow this is wide open now you can see
how we are
how are we how are you you guys all just
straighten your posture
yeah they are trying to get into it
wasn't expecting company maybe try
getting into the shot a little bit I'm
just I'm in the shot dude well you don't
want to get shot like JFK oh dude whoa
that's he didn't get shots he just did
that they encrypt they put a it was the
first Elon Musk brain chip
he got too smart yeah they're like boom
boom boom boom
sorry play with that so all right what
do you think about JFK
he was trying to hang on to the gold
standard and he was trying to get rid of
secret societies so the CIA had him
assassinated I think he was just
left-wing I think he was just generally
left-wing and they were afraid of
someone who actually believed and did
what so he wanted to do he's a left wing
and then he flies right they're like
dude this guy can't be running the world
and clapping Marilyn Monroe's cheeks we
gotta put a stop to this this is too
much would that be like assassinated
Fidel Castro or tried to so him [__]
that woman would be like Trump [__]
Kardashians no be like you're a [__]
Stormy Daniels has a great joke on it
and I'm not gonna ruin it but yeah you
should just drop it because the sun
already covered it and it's like way
better than whatever the [__]
I'm sorry
I'm getting aggro maybe I subconsciously
listen to that yeah
um
JFK more like Jews [__]
[__]
whoa dude what you're not supposed to
say cakes
I'm about to say his Instagram handle go
for it shout it out it's all say a slur
let's go around the table wait you can't
repeat it yeah what's your favorite
racist
all right million dollar idea okay only
Paradise
[Laughter]
it's a paradise but he's got nothing to
lose
a paradise Paradise yeah a pair of dice
two dice and each side has a slur on it
and you just have to throw that [__] and
scream at the podcast and the uh Snake
Eyes is you know what
the Snake Eyes oh every one out of 36
guests wait one side should be I have a
gun that's their career room just erase
mistakes a little bit jackpot because
then it goes from offending people to
fearing for their lives
have you reoffended ever
I never offended in the first place
reoffended what did he offend
probably the sensibility of some decent
hard-working Christians
trying to angle me into admitting to war
crimes that I have not committed
uh how do you feel about the allegations
against you
um I think that they are wildly
exaggerated and that
I don't feel bad about any of what I do
[Laughter]
in fact I'm proud of it
I would like to tell people about it
I'm listening so do you think that women
deserve more or less than men
well honestly
the women and men that I personally know
the women all make more money oh they're
all of them the ladies are crushing so I
do not see uh super scientific survey
you did of the people that you talk to
or whatever oh really like I should not
judge my opinions off of my personal
life like that's ignorant of me I think
it'd be ignorant to just believe what
other people say Hans I'm doing why I
listen to scientists
you mean the people that told you to
take the vaccines
the people that tell you that your
Cricket is safe to eat do you listen to
those scientists yeah because it's me
how many crickets do you have to eat
you don't have to add anything
don't buy his crickets it's disgusting
whoa dude you're gonna [__] on my
business
Hans are you [__] on the cricket man
the cricket's already [__] on your
business I see him he's growing antennas
as we speak what do you do with all the
cricket [__] do you wash the Crickets
yeah [__] yeah we wash the Crickets how
they get crooked they go through like a
video there's a there's another Cricket
they get tumbled around
I think he had missed it and then they
throw them in a rock polisher dehydrated
and then they get powderized and they're
completely dry so there's no room for
bacteria or parasites to grow you're
stuck on the algorithm too
The Rock washing algorithm
why all right I gotta leave Phyllis I
gotta go be a door guy so see you guys
I'm proud of you good job but
good job good job bud you're doing it
you are leaving the podcast successfully
most people never get out
that's true yeah this place is a Rat's
Nest I'm surprised that you can fit all
this in here
well my snacks you mean a vagina
yeah this is the podcast [__] for sure
it's got these red drapes thanks fridge
thanks Rich God
[Laughter]
what are you reading
um I will tell you in a second can you
read it out loud he's reading something
about crickets Ridge is a door guy at
the mothership right no
no oh okay good uh because I'm writing a
rap about the door guys at the
Mothership
I thought about reading it and I'm
definitely not gonna do that
someone in the comments said let me know
if you need Addie's
let me know if you need Addies and ATX
dude you got [__]
Addie Slingers in your [__] God I got
my Shooters out
what are they offering that he's at
Dallas I'm going to Dallas this weekend
Oh in Austin yeah there's he's like I'm
the Eddie plug of Austin dude
the APA Instagram group
I want to go back and read all that
later Eddie yeah that's super healthy
you don't read the comments no never
it's not good for you yeah why do you
read the comments
um because I might there might be like a
compliment or two in there yeah so
you're digging for compliments you're
willing to Wade through the [__] for the
compliments
yeah I mean well the the internet
doesn't like me very much
every podcast I've seen the comments are
usually like yeah that guy wasn't great
ouch well don't you think that they
aren't great and why listen to a society
that can't even give Health Care to its
citizens well the people that I know in
real life really like me and that's what
matters yeah yeah like your survey of
women that are all making a lot of money
yeah
they're called strippers
just pretending to like me okay they
actually like they're one of the good
ones
[Music]
podcasts
this is a podcast
I mean did I do it right do you want to
end it yeah I had fun do you want to end
it no I don't want to end it let's not
end it okay I'm going Eli
yes let's talk let's can you talk yeah
um I've been doing a lot of thinking and
uh it hurts to think so I'm trying not
to think anymore
yeah bro thinking sucks
making this for losers the thinking is
for dumbasses dude
you could think yourself and do a whole
heap
problems
remember thoughts running wild when you
think
Okay so
first of all
a lot of the uh the money in society is
like held by the rich so let's try to
like
I got something for that at least that
so I think the fact that the one percent
hold most of the wealth that applies to
literally everything the one percent
of musicians
there's a hundred credits and the rich
have 99 and everyone else has one is
that okay because one percent always has
more money or if they have 75 and the
rest of the country has 25 what is the
correct balance and are we maybe
exaggerated too much in the favor of one
of one percent well you're trying to
bring morality into an algorithmic
problem it's not about immorality it's
about efficiency it's not efficient to
have all the money trapped but it
doesn't matter you can't do anything
about it it's going to be that can
unionize and we can give labor power
back instead of making laws to make rich
people richer okay so if you took if you
completely went full communism and took
everyone's money and redistributed
easily so everyone had the okay well
let's say you just did that let's say
you gave everyone equal amount of money
uh-huh in a few years it would be back
to where we are now the wealth would
redistribute itself then why isn't
Sweden like that now why is America
unequal but Sweden hasn't gone back to
that they have more equality because
they're all white no that's not because
they're all white it's because they
figure their [__] out Sweden have you
been to Sweden no so then you don't know
what you're talking about I can look at
graphs
written by lying scientists so what
scientists support what you say I don't
know man honestly nobody knows what the
[__] they're talking about but I there
is a connection between like the whole
the nature of hierarchies is just
inherent in nature and but that's not
like what we need to fix right now our
problem isn't that we don't have enough
hierarchies that there's too much maybe
we could do less and still have
hierarchy okay what I'm saying is the
human heart beats 90 beats per minute
and what you're saying is the human
heart should be 300 times per minute and
I'm using that as a metaphor to say I'm
just stating
and the just suggesting something so
foreign and horrible and not possible
and it doesn't ever work correct
[Laughter]
okay that's sad well I feel sad now but
yeah I dude it bums me out too man like
I think I got uh I'll go in these
negative things where I'll be like oh I
suck and then I'm like wait I don't
really suck that much and everyone else
sucks and then I'll suck humanity is
just kind of doomed and the best thing
you can do is just
try to make a bunch of jokes about it
till you die so what's like a good joke
about everyone dying
um I think everyone dying is pretty
funny
everybody dying
yeah everybody is gonna die I'm dying
right now all right they're all dying
right now yeah I was about to say it's
crazy that we're gonna leave I got a
joke oh and uh you've heard it before
and you're gonna be like what are you
doing and then I'm gonna do something
and you're gonna be like whoa is it a
bill no why did the chicken cross the
road take it to the other side suicide
joke
that's a suicide that's a joke about
suicide it crossed the road so it can
get hit by a car to cross over to the
other other side that's what that joke
means it crossed the road to get to the
other side wow and that's a common
parlance for heaven
I didn't think about that they probably
saw a chicken in the roads like why'd
that chicken cross the road well want to
get to the other side do you believe in
reincarnation totally yeah there's a
bunch of Articles of children that have
past life experiences whoa and then they
found the previous family that they were
with
and he was like just found two idiots
there was this little white kid and he's
like I used to be a black woman in
Chicago and then they found the black
woman's family in Chicago and he was
able to point to every family member and
say their names and like remembered his
life as a black mother to those children
on YouTube
no it was in uh some like Business
Journal article or something it was not
on one of those like as long as real
truth unveiled it wasn't like one of
those it was like a legitimate news
source well I mean you know nothing's
wrong you don't even believe scientists
in Sweden how are you going to believe a
business article about children seeing
black people I believe whatever suits my
narrative
I believe whatever suits my narrative
and I think that's how everyone should
live you should just look for reasons to
think that you're right
well Michael is right about being half
asian and just being really cool
and just being like hey I'm the cool guy
like a lot of Asians aren't cool so hey
if you want to hang out with like an
Asian that you can hang with
here I am
that's me
that's us I [__] with Asians man I grew
up in Irvine I grew up in Newport News
and there weren't a lot of Asians but
there were a lot of I'm Filipino and
there's a lot of Filipino people in
Virginia Beach when I moved out there as
an adult I saw there's this whole
[__] community of Filipinos meanwhile
in Newport News there was no Community
like that and these two locations these
two cities are only like 45 minutes
apart
and we grew up in Newport News as a
Filipino family
that sounds like a convenience store
yeah it's at the airport it's [__]
yeah it sounds like you can buy some
Newports and get a newspaper but it's
literally they call it bad news
Newport Jews I used to say that too
because they give out so many speeding
tickets so that's how they generate
Revenue theirs they give a lot of
speeding tickets and [__] it's like get
people in the court system Northeastern
towns that have just spiraled out of
control yeah they can't bring any
tourists into this [__] area so they
just punish the people that do wander in
there like it's a [__] like you're in
the wilderness on RuneScape was your
area considered the DMV
yeah Dallas metro village DC Maryland
Virginia yeah my buddy from Virginia had
DMV tattooed on him and in California
that's what we call the Department of
Motor Vehicles that's what they call it
here too so you know yeah
vehicles
so we were always like automobiles yeah
there's no vehicle department they
yeah
that means car
I thought it meant coochie
no you didn't I'm trying to Google it
and there's no way you thought that
koche
how how is that not really similar
is this live or volume oh yeah no more
Oreo fortune cookies children the real
scientists bruh hitting that Vape way
too hard
bro hitting he's calling someone a bruh
who's hitting it way too hard he's
hitting the Vape way too hard
Ricky Brown
comment in the comment section so what
do you want to say Elia to the
commenters your favorite people to speak
to
um you should listen to my rap albums on
Spotify Brodie lowballer you have a rap
album I have two rap albums with over a
million plays bro that's cool was the
two rap albums combined have over a
million or each one is 500 000 combined
I'm coming out with a third album pretty
soon nice I used to rap in high school
and then I got addicted to drugs and
then I went to jail and then I started
doing stand-up
yeah I only have the confidence to do
that because my friends laugh at it and
I'm like oh if my friends are making my
friends laugh then that's cool but if so
would you kill Jews if it made you ever
okay why do that would you kill Jews if
it made your friends laugh what if
Hitler
what if Hitler was
uh
uh Hey Eli so what do you think about
Joe Biden
senile and a robot and a guy in a mask
you know senile is really close to
penile so
maybe you're kind of attracted to Joe
Biden and maybe I'm in denial about
those penile attracts the river in Egypt
denial
what are you gonna say before you not
too high I am too high again
I smoke weed and I just get way too high
but you weren't High just like five
minutes ago it's starting to settle in
for the last few months I've been having
these epiphanies every time I do a lot
of drugs and the Epiphany like almost
every time was like hey you should go
sober
wow that's your body telling you
something I think to go sober yeah I
gotta say I never say that I never
thought I'd be able to be happy sober
and I'm sober and I'm pretty happy and
there's absolutely nothing funny about
that it's not good for comedy I kind of
story that I've heard a million times
but I'm it's the first time I'm living
it
that's fun
so what is it that like you're getting
from it that maybe you could translate
to other people
who have heard the story a million times
no one has heard my story
because this just started 19 days ago
19 days fresh so what did the first 30
days sober and then I started dabbling
with mushrooms again and then I started
dabbling with weed recently but it's
been like a hundred words
well I'm gonna I'm gonna tell you my
plan actually I have a hole of the whole
thing so I'm gonna build up Golden
Cricket to make like millions of dollars
yeah and then I'm gonna also be sober
and then I want to be like one of those
motivational speakers that are like you
just gotta change your mindset but like
be completely insane about it you want
to make it a joke because that's
actually what you want to do that's how
your brain operates exactly Andrew Tate
no I'm 173 days sober from alcohol
I think it's crazy that a lot of people
want to inspire like just out of nowhere
because they need it so much or they're
that's how they operate us with
inspiration so they're like how do I get
other people to do this too it's like
they haven't even done anything but they
still want to do it reality is a pyramid
scheme
like everything you have no original
thoughts everything you think is because
you mix together some other stuff
someone else told you every word you use
you didn't make up any of those words
we're all just copying and pasting
different we're just we're not even real
we don't even have personalities we're
just like a collage of like cartoons and
family members we studied growing up
that's great that's beautiful I'm Asian
I'm part of something larger than myself
yeah yeah no that's that's another thing
I realized with with the getting sober
stuff I was like too focused on like me
and like building my life and then I'm
like dude I just want to be part of the
collective and like I mean I already
have been but like you know I like I
like being a good friend to people and
helping people around me and
uh it's one of them I mean it's yeah
it's the biggest one really because if
if you gave me a
if you offered me 10 million dollars to
cut off all of my friends that there's
no chance I would take that
but if you said I'd cut everybody off
for 10 mil
I'd cut my wife off for 10 mil back
sorry honey I'll be back under a fake
name give me a couple years
I'd cut a wife off did you cut your wife
out your significant other for 10 mil or
all your family members too that's well
it's easier honestly about 10 minutes
dude your family your loved ones that's
what I'm talking about like bro for 10
mil God could you do it though kind of
thinking about it like that's the people
in my life bro we just never talk to
them ever again for 10 [__] million
dollars no they all die no no I'm not
killing them for 10 million no I just
what if I just could just watch them
from a distance but I could never say
anything to them because I took the 10
mil
you know what I'm saying like I would
just have like how's my wife doing oh my
God she's got a new husband [__] dude
turn this [__] off looks like she's
moved on
and then you you spend a bunch of money
to try to get over it and you end up
developing problems and then you're
broke you still can't talk to anyone
yeah yeah yeah at the end is that a
movie I feel like that's a movie
you get 10 racks you just can't talk to
any of them in an audiobook it's an
audio book now here
so yeah I mean if I could just not talk
to my family and stuff uh that would be
kind of horrible but you know like isn't
that like who we are is like our family
like when we die that we're gonna live
on through the memories that they have
of us so if you're cutting yourself off
from them you're cutting yourself off
from immortality
yeah I like that angle
I strive for immortality in the sense
that I will leave a lasting effect or be
remembered in a significant way before I
die yeah like Hitler no I wouldn't do
something extreme like Hitler yeah I
want to do something legendary you
haven't been rejected from Comedy you
haven't been fully kicked out of the
comedy world
who has Hitler was fully kicked out of
the art world
if I got kicked out of com oh yeah a
comedian that becomes Hitler because he
got kicked out of his local Open Mic
scene that's what that's literally what
the Joker was literally what happened to
me I got kicked out of my Open Mic scene
you knitted Mike he did one show at a
showcase and then it went crazy it's
like you got a mic bro wait do you know
guy named Joker do you know a guy named
case squishy one Mike yeah
case quiz you know
uh he's he does he's like does open mics
and some comedy in Virginia Okay so
okay he's like Indian
why is that wanna sound
Indian dude yeah Richmond
probably I don't know it sounds familiar
I can't call it though
he was like an internet friend of mine
where he would just like
inspired by my comedic journey and then
we were just like message back and forth
and then he would he had a [__] Open
Mic pen pal yeah like a digital like
what'd you do yeah wow neat you got
booked on that killer no nothing didn't
get booked that's nice I haven't been
getting booked on anything during South
by I got hit with a barrage of just
random last minute Mike do you want to
go on the show and I was like yeah like
I was at work I might get work and
people were like yo go up I'm like all
right bet and I put my then resume work
after the set ends
I did that at a secret show Once too
that's something I should tell your uh
Open Mic pen pal yeah that was
definitely something I would tell an
open mic pinpal right here we haven't
spoken in years damn you cut off your
Open Mic pen pal how much was it 10 mil
you circumcised them yeah you
circumcised them and then it just
regenerated like Wolverine and I just
have a piece of his foreskin in your
pocket right now pull it out show us
it's like in a little Ziploc bag he's
like yeah bro it's just it's my boy is
it to sunlight it'll regrow the rest of
him and he'll just show up here wow what
if that's that's your teleportation
thing right there Hans you have to hit
sir heat and then they pre-gen yeah
petri dish yeah it's like a circumcised
over and over again every time you want
to travel hear me out hear me comedian
hear me out you upload your DNA to a
computer which is already the circle and
then you Quantum compute send that data
over to another universe and then they
print out the genetic material using
that DNA code okay that's like almost
possible and then you just that's how
you solidificate to death on Mars
no further than Mars terraform we can
already get to Mars teleporting
yeah
so that's fun what do these commenters
think of this Hans do you like being the
fun Asian guy
no you don't like it yeah that's I'm not
a fun Asian guy yeah you are you're like
the wholesome fun Asian guy
I'm more like the sad
communist sad communist agent is like
are you a communist yeah how does
communism work like if you were
president what would you do you make uh
people that are the bosses pay their
employees fairly the end what's fair
what they earn for the company
so there has to be if someone's in a
profit for something so what if what if
what if someone comes to McDonald's and
they don't have any customers for that
day but they work a nine hour shift they
should get no money
um maybe you could tie them over maybe
you could help them out
so you want to base the economy on Merit
and uh Hans would you run for president
I am running for president all right
let's uh let's roll let's run some uh
Hans what are you gonna do
about the Fukushima
radiation crisis that's touching the
western coast of California right I
guess I'm the president of Japan right
now
as a Japanese president I would no is
the president of the United States
there's the Japan shits leaking into
California they're like hey is there a
way is that you're bringing this up yeah
kind of I don't know last time I checked
it looked like it was heading straight
towards California and Mexico because
the way that the Pacific Ocean flows all
that radiation it would like fan it out
across the Pacific like a graph you
could see it like progressively going
west
Simpson fish
huh so are you like a libertarian
uh I I guess that would be the closest
thing to call me so why can't you sell
your child
um because the buyers would probably
[__] it
oh yeah that's Pros would you sell your
family why do we have to donate organs
dog I want to sell my parents uh organs
bro yeah well I should be able to sell
my family members organs why do I have
to donate that [__] I think I think the
medical industry should be socialist I
think we can cherry pick we can have
capitalism here and socialism here we
got capitalism and crickets but
socialism and comedy no socialism in uh
medical care I mean you got yeah it's
got to be nuanced you can't just [__]
make everything Capital if you make
everything capitalism that's why you
have the price of uh like [__] that's
why healthcare costs so much because
they [__] price gouge all of that
[__] like yeah 400 bucks for too much
communism or else gay people might be
too comfortable
gays are the some of the most
comfortable people I've ever met they're
very comfortable have you seen a gay
person's house that you make me
uncomfortable
do you think communism is good for gay
people or bad for bad gay people
bad because they wouldn't be able to
pick their outfits they'd have to wear
those horrible jumpers I mean they're
already trying to distribute evenly
their come everywhere
I love that for them
so what are you saying what do you think
about Fidel Castro do you think is he a
hero of yours do you admire him
uh yeah
would you say he's one of the greatest
leaders of all time
I would say he made Cuba function
and that's pretty cool it's right under
America's nose it's like he did like an
impossible thing I think Fidel was
pretty cool honestly what I what I
really think about communism is I think
that
there's a very good chance that it would
work
but
it hasn't because capitalism has always
shut it down and been like uh it's never
gonna work yeah like feudalism try to do
the capitalism but it failed
because Time Marches On and Germany
became
traditionalized and everyone came over
here to America like capitalism works
for me so I have no desire to try to
change the system right but no one's
saying capitalism is your life no one's
like I want to stop you living your life
the way you're living it there's a lot
of people actually well that's not the
the goal of
Bernie Sanders is to stop you from
having a Tesla
I think a lot of people personally
they're like oh communism means like I
can't do what I do
but I mean
I'm sure that you can I'm sure we can
make it work well it's communism saying
communism is a good idea is like saying
everyone should be able to fly like yeah
that would be cool but like that's not
gonna happen
censorship
but we should still invest in gem packs
jet packs would be sick just because we
can't fly we shouldn't be like well give
up entirely and just get good at
crawling
no you would have a capitalistic company
come along and provide affordable jet
packs for everyone so why can't we have
a capitalistic company come around and
give communism to everyone
because you would need money in exchange
for products or services and you
couldn't get money in exchange for money
and if you just if the services provided
were basic things like food and housing
then that would be money in exchange
then that would still be capitalism
so I don't think that's possible well
then everything's capitalism
if you buy something from a store you
just capitalized on some eggs yeah
you're supporting child slavery if you
eat chocolate you're supporting chickens
which cross the other side to the other
side suicidal chickens man what are we
gonna do about these guys Gary Foust
says I want to fly
Gary I want to see those [__] tits
man he has nice tits so what do you want
to do uh should we call it or do you
want to like say something about
chickens
I ran out of jokes a while ago I just
I was just gonna answer anything I was
asked basically
yeah let's let's put him in the hot seat
yeah oh [__] yeah okay he's gonna take
it really lethargically and use our own
momentum against us okay sure yeah well
should a six-year-old girls be allowed
to be forced to take testosterone
and does that mean it's okay if I do
steroids too oh there's someone's saying
depends do these [__] do these little
[__] want to get jacked do they want
results because that's what they're
gonna have to do
I don't call it a shortcut yeah they
call it a fast track
[Laughter]
yes so your daughter should kill she's
gonna keep yeah yeah all right let's
give another did you think that uh
we should force some six-year-old girls
to take testosterone come on man okay
what are we gonna do about the polyvinyl
chloride explosion in East Palestine
Ohio hold on let me sort this thing out
with what'd you say Hans one more time
you said the exact same thing as me
would you force a six-year-old to get
you you just asked
if they should be able to now I'm saying
should we man made it make them well so
here's the thing
if they live on a farm and we're
building Society all over again
like let's say the bombs dropped
all right now we're six months in a
radioactive future
we're living in the Fallout you know
what I'm saying we're rebuilding Society
yeah roid everyone up and get them to
work even the girls
have the girls out there pushing
boulders
with their shoulders what if we're
fighting Russia and we need more
soldiers oh yeah right up the chicks go
for it right up those girls you again
rocket launchers that's such a good man
now why don't you identify as a hero for
your country
come on Bessie take your hero drugs
we'll let you grow your armpit hair out
join the Navy children should not be on
hormones
well then how are we gonna build this
[__] dough
we got beer we have like seahorses you
know how seahorses can change gender
depending on like the temperature of the
water
if we got like a war going on America
can have double the capacity of any
other country it's just women soldiers
dude we're such fairies
um ask me another question
yeah East Palestine polyvinyl chloride
explosion dude I don't even know like
what can't develop a chemical that can
eat it and dispose of it safely you
could make a chemical that could eat
that [__] and turn it into something
safe
they can do it with like no they burned
it and then it turned into eight yeah so
you'll have to create a chemical
compound to spray in the air that would
actively deodorize basically like it
would kill whatever that [__] is like
that would be hard to do no you just
capture you just need something basic
capture it and then study what the [__]
is in the air and then find like use the
applied Knowledge from what you've
learned from what you've captured in
that little jar or whatever and then I
[__] synthesize some [__] that can
eat that [__] bro but I think release it
in [__] crop dusters all over that
town the water's probably [__] forever
I don't think you'll ever be able to fix
the water dude it's like in the soil and
it's in the sewage and it's it's dude
it's everywhere now do you think it was
intentional
you think they're intentionally
poisoning you think somebody like in
China like hacked in a computer is like
me play joke
[__] makes this [__] train no it
was
it was uh funding they cut the funding
on the [__] people working there so
they had only two dudes on that big ass
train with all that [__] Hazmat [__]
dude you haven't noticed the pattern of
Pharmacy you see how easy it is to
[__] you see how easy it is to flip a
[__] train though the railroads are
[__] dog [__] we built them over 18.
we built them in the 1800s that's how
most of them are is made by [__]
Chinese people during Wild West times
bro the shits are rickety
shutting down our weather balloons
yeah we're not bad drivers they're just
bad they were just studying the
railroads like damn we gotta fix it we
gotta come back over here
in the 1800s so sad yeah
you know they didn't put their heart
into it because the Great Wall of
China's still standing
yeah
stupid next question
railroads it's funny because like uh the
Chinese and they're like they're hacking
us and it's like did they hack us or do
we just have really shitty railroad yeah
you can't even like it's all you know
it's equally possible those two things
are very late yeah or it could have been
both they could have been like oh look
at that shitty railroad they haven't
maintain it in 200 years I always get a
good seat for that derailment they knew
it was coming
Ohio
it's going to [__] door up
two Asian dudes judging via Drone
footage laughing maniacally because they
know it's about to [__] oh they see us
they shoot us down now
who built the pyramids and why who built
the pyramids
me in a past life
I was a being that could [__] turn
sand into stone and I pinched them up
from the ground like this
that's how your fingers are yeah I
[__] like you're stroking a titty in
space yeah
I was a gaseous being that could [__]
reach my hands on Earth and mold it in
any way I wanted I made people and
[__]
I want to do mushrooms with this guy
when I relapse just kidding
it's called relapse
um no I mean I don't know probably like
seven eight grams me too
but that was when I was drinking and
seven eight grams while I was drinking
feels like an eighth now sober from
drinking so I want to see what taking a
whole [__] quarter would be like now
yeah uh it was awesome uh I was
I was in a very bad mood at the time and
I don't do that I never tried it I never
do that I was just like I'm just gonna
try to eat as many as much as I can
really happy yeah convince I always try
to convince never do anything that makes
you happy whoa it just makes your life
harder in the long run communism
you're pretty communist sign dude yeah
you're you're looking pretty communist
today you look a little sad and gray
well uh I gotta check to deposit in my
communist bank account so I need to get
out of here pretty soon
well let's all say racial slur and we
can end the podcast [__]
grab the safest one right quick
Martian Martian
that's gonna be offensive in 20 years
just watch
I'm gonna get canceled for this but the
hard r
at yeah martian with a hard R Mars
Jesus yeah harsh and my Martian
okay
how to do anything and
are we off